uh responding very directly to the the
panel's title in a request for policy
recommendations and doing so very
quickly and great com strangely enough I
don't need the same that was the
quotation conclusion I was going to have
so now I'm going to save a little
time
um yes Mr chairman distinguished guest
ladies and
gentlemen
uh I'm delighted to be back in Vienna to
address you and wish to thank the
organizers for giving me the opportunity
to be the last speaker as it is written
in sacred text the first shall be last
and the last
first in the world conference on human
rights uh here in Geneva um in Vienna
they adopted the Vienna declaration and
program of action referred to as the DPA
which recognized and
affirmed and I quote that all human
rights derive from the dignity and worth
inherent in the human person and that
human person is the central subject of
Human Rights and fundamental freedoms
and consequently should be the Principal
beneficiary and should participate
actively in the realization of these
rights and
freedoms it's article one States the
World Conference on human rights
reaffirms the solemn commitment of all
states states to fulfill their
obligations to promote Universal respect
for and observance and protection of all
human rights and fundamental freedoms
for all in
accordance with the charter of the
United Nations other instruments related
to Human Rights the bill of Human Rights
it means and international
law the universal nature of these rights
and freedoms is beyond question
question in its penate
paragraph the DPA concludes with a
follow-up to the World Conference on
human rights and further recommends that
the commission on human rights the
commission on human rights annually
review the the progress towards this end
Yes you heard me correctly the
commission on human
rights in articles publ
in 1994 on slavery in Sudan threats
against special reporter Gaspar buau
since
1997 on blasphemy at the United Nations
Universal human rights and human rights
in Islam and islamism grow stronger at
the United Nations stealth Jihad at the
UN and many others we have Illustrated
how a systematic effort has been made at
the United Nations by certain member
states to
replace some of the of the dominant
paradigms of international
relations now referred to as
complimentary standards by the OIC and
the UN
diplomatically its diplomatic language
already in September 1992 6 months
before the Vienna conference the final
Declaration of the conference of the 108
non-aligned countries held at Jakarta
Indonesia stressed differences in
cultures in quotes and implied that
differences in the interpretation of
Human Rights should be recognized this
became soon became the cultural
relativism Ploy which we have warned
against systematically since
then at the recent 13th session of the
Human Rights Council in Geneva I'm
speaking of the 23rd of March which is
hardly 3 weeks ago two weeks ago
speaking jointly for the association for
World education and World Union for
progress Judaism in the context of the
Vienna DPA we paid homage to Sergio Vio
deelo the then High Commissioner for
Human Rights was tragically slaughtered
with 20 other members of his staff in
the Baghdad Canal Hotel bombing of 19th
of August 2003 after the UN refused
allied military protection putting their
faith in the fact that they're coming
from the UN he was there as the
secretary General's special
representative in Iraq in his last
report on the followup to the World
Conference on human rights he
pertinently stated the Hopeless mess
into which the commission had fallen it
was this report that led to an attempt
to improve the structure and mechanism
on human rights and finally to the
creation of the Human Rights Council we
shall quote his courageous words then 7
years later and as we did at the
commission soon after his death and
recently again for they were a harbinger
of the Gathering stealth storm that
resulted in a decision to replace the
discredited commission with what was
intended to be a responsible body of the
Human Rights
Council
quote membership of the commission on
human rights this is Vio deelo
must carry responsibilities I therefore
wonder whether the time has not come for
the commission itself to develop a go
code of guidelines for access to
membership of the commission and a code
of conduct for members while they serve
on the commission after all the
commission on human rights has a duty to
humanity and the members of the
commission must themselves set the
example of adherence to the
international human rights Norms in
practice as well as in LA law his
conclusion then is still meaningful
today when we consider the disastrous
followups follow-ups excuse me to the
Vienna declaration and the two World
conferences on
racism uh known as Durban 1 in 2001 and
what is often called Durban 2 which took
place in Geneva last year despite what
is propagated worldwide by the Durban
idolators and the current catastroph and
the and the current catastrophic Human
Rights Council here are deo's
words again without Universal respect
for human rights the vision of the
charter of a world of Peace grounded in
respect for human rights and economic
and social justice will remain an
illusion let us vindicate the Charter's
Vision by being faithful to the
universal implementation of human rights
in doing so we shall continue in the
direction of History rather than
allowing ourselves to be diverted from
the course we know to be just a year
later in 2004 when introducing
recommendations for a new Human Rights
Council secretary General Kofi Anan
declared that the commission had been
undermined by allowing participation of
countries whose purpose was quote not to
strengthen human rights but to protect
themselves against criticism or to
criticize others end of quote his chief
of staff there mark Malo Brown not
Gordon of course put it more bluntly
quote for the great Global public the
performance or non-performance of the
Human Rights Commission has become the
litmus test of un renewal end of quote
little has changed since in reality it
is worse except that the Great
Expectations have been dissipated by a
gloomy uh Despair and worse to come for
those who do not have eyes to see or ISS
to hear as a veteran NGO human rights
Defender since
1986 at the United Nations in Geneva I
have watched what is grandly called the
International Community at the palaso
which I sometimes call in remembrance of
ludrick II the palish Fran
Stein sending
incontinently recklessly the staircase
which leads to a dark Gulf it is a fine
broad staircase at the beginning but
after a bit the carpet ends a little
further on there are only flag stones
and a little further on still these
break Beneath Your Feet this Timeless
description by Churchill of Britain's
situation at a crucial moment on the
24th of March 1938 in the House of
Commons during dur the During the period
of grotesque appeasement gives a vivid
image of the general climate nowadays at
the UN Human Rights Council the problem
is that everyone knows but no one wants
to recognize the fact that the emperor
strutting in his pal in his Paladin
announcing
royally rather
is Stark naked three months ago we gave
a longer presentation in the European
Parliament in
Brussels that text contains much
documentation was available here for
some background information but
unfortunately in a limited number of
photo stats due to lack of facilities
you may also be interested in a recent
piece that was posted on Jihad watch in
regard to violence against women and our
recent comments on F GM the origo Mali
the origin of evil Council event when we
were again
stopped a classic example of the game of
Nations Council where o OIC constantly
tries to rule the roost also available
on Robert Spencer's Jihad watch with the
Vivid unbelievable un video Sharia gate
shipwreck as we called it uh would also
give you an idea 26 minutes you won't
believe when you see the Egyptian
delegate waving my statement above his
head which he shouldn't have had with a
mustache looking like Adolf Hitler it's
the mustache favorite actually uh in
Egypt there's Association for mustaches
in Hitler's mustache as first place and
he actually spoke about Islam will not
be
crucified in this Council and the
crucifixion was if you link FGM in any
way to Islam whereas everyone knows that
in Egypt according to UNICEF figures 96%
of all girls every year are mutilated
because of the shafia interpretation of
the the shafia of sharia law and this of
course is not allowed anymore it cannot
uh be used and when I was speaking at
the same time uh about the stoning of
women in Iran and Sudan and pointing out
in Iran they are buried up to their
waist in pits and blunt stones are used
thereby increasing the agony and death
and that the marriage age for girls
remains at 9 years old since the exam
Islamic Republic the resolution uh the
revolution in
1979 reduced the age by half from 18 as
it was with sha until uh nine now what
is amusing is the crass um uh the
crassness uh to which The Usual Suspects
are willing to go at the council here
are the words of the Iranian delegates
speaking on a point of order which was
not a point of order it was a response
and he was reprimanded very slightly by
the Romanian president Mr chairman the
statement and the references made by the
speaker in the statement is for there
nothing to do with the realities of my
country I just wanted for the record he
said that the stoning of women for
alleged adultery still occurs regularly
in Iran end of quote it's not true it is
completely false and out of the question
now they have a penal legislation
articles 10 I won't read them to you 10
100 102 104 which explain exactly how
you Stone them and that you mustn't have
Stones which are too blunt because they
have to be in the maximum uh of uh pain
during this uh well I've spoking about
that in a statement made in Geneva in
2008 by the courageous Iranian Noble
Prize
winner shiran abadi a girl in her native
country is considered this is her
speaking an adult and liable to
punishment even execution at 9 and aoy
15 she totally rejected cultural
relativism I'm speaking of the Nobel
Prize laurate Shirin uh eadi who spoke
also at AMR University on the 17th of
October 2008 where she said very
pertinently I have always opposed the
Islamic Declaration on human rights 2
months later she spoke again at the un
uh where I asked her a question which
can be find again on Jihad watch for
those who were interested despite all
this last week the UN elected Iran to
its Commission on the status of women
not to the council which they wanted
with a four-year seat on the influential
human rights body this was a few days
after Iran dropped its outrageous demand
for a return to the Human Rights Council
it should be noted that the special
status of women Commission according to
its website is quote dedicated
exclusively to gender equality and
advancement of women Iran will be joined
next year by the Democratic Republic of
Congo and Zimbabwe to give an idea of
how function in the UN because they are
in a group of countries which have the
right North America South America Europe
wherever East to have their place uh in
the ballet schwanstein if I may uh put
it like that to up you to update you on
the latest situation 10 weeks ago OIC
Secretary General L uh el e melodin isan
noblu delivered a statement at what is
called the high segment uh beginning of
the 13th session I prefer to use the
word high futen we have ministers coming
and it lasts a whole week he concluded
on what he called a happy note again and
I won't read you um the whole thing it's
again in the in Jihad watch I would just
conclude the revealing passages which we
hear all the time at the UN which even
Mary Robinson with her Palestinian
Muslim advisor used in 2002 which I
reproduced which is unbelievable here is
what isan said uh we take pride that
Islam was the first religion that called
for full equality among people
regardless of their race language ethnic
origin social St Etc this equality has
been associated with preserving human
dignity a concept that goes far beyond
that of human rights the establishment
of the commission will introduce the
commission being their new I didn't read
that their new commission Islamic
Commission on human rights which the
High Commissioner on human rights was
obliged more or less I hope she didn't
believe it to say it was a big Advance
the establishment of the commission of
human rights in Islam will introduce a
paradigm shift within the OIC in the way
Universal Human Rights and Freedoms flow
together with Islamic values to offer
maybe as Michael HT would have put it to
offer a coherent and strong system aimed
at facilitating the full enjoyment of
all human rights of the member states a
very strange affirmation he thereby
confirmed that the 1990 Kyo declaration
ation human rights in Islam continues to
be hailed steadfastly by the OIC as
having Primacy for its 57 member states
over the universal Declaration of Human
Rights I would remind you that articles
24 and 25 of that 90 uh 1990 K
Declaration state clearly that all the
Articles which look like the universal
declaration but they're not are
dependent on Sharia law and Sharia law
men and women who if a Muslim have no
equality and uh infidels have no
equality of course with
mlim that nothing could be clearer than
this solemn Announcement by the OIC
Secretary General but then came a worst
clanger on the 19th of April only 3
weeks ago when a meeting took place at
the OIC headquarters in in jeda Saudi
Arabia between the OIC Secretary General
and High Commissioner for human rights
NE
NM P who was on a won a general visit
this was clearly a follow-up to isang
glue's statement of the UN Human Rights
Council we learn on the OIC website the
High Commissioner congratulated the the
Secretary General on the prospective
establishment of the commission and
assured full support of her office in
its formative phase there's I'm afraid
nothing else she could have done the OIC
website refers to the independent
permanent Commission on human rights by
which I strongly advise you to read
There is of course uh no time uh for me
to do that here uh this and other
attempts at stealth Jihad to mule
freedom of expression at the at the UN
Human Rights Council is being
effectively challenged by Western
countries and Nos and is also possible
the influence of cyber State space
conveying such news worldwide is having
a beneficial effect what we were able to
say in our 10 statements 2 minutes each
only last month at the Human Rights
Council without being stopped and in the
absence of Egypt's mustached comic
Troublemaker is indic
the blatant judeophobia anti-Semitism in
the Arab Muslim world is exemplified by
the two Es Esco books I left
documentation on the back we discovered
on display on the 60th anniversary of
the universal Declaration of Human
Rights and described our public
complaint documation a year ago 12th of
January 2009 what is most disturbing is
that isesco the scholarly wing of the
OIC countries have an educational
partnership with UNESCO since 1981 yet
this changes nothing the documents on
all this were also available here what
is our policy recommendation and I will
conclude that's good thanks it is to
oppose every attempt by islamists or
their allies to introduce Islamic values
into our society those Sharia linked
values are today alien to our
judeo-christian Enlightenment values on
which our modern democracies societies
have been built we must oppose attempts
to create parallel systems of Justice we
must fight every step of the way or all
attempts to create Sharia courts all of
us Christians Jews Hindus humanists and
especially Muslims must re reject Sharia
law because as the Islamic scholar
Hassan Mahmud has clearly stated and as
we can see Muslims are the first victims
of Islamic law I usually concl well I
will conclude by saying it's now 65
years since the horrors of the second
world war and the founding of the United
Nations a body often more divided
regionally politically and spiritually
than United the principal aim of the
1948 Universal Declaration of Human
Rights was to create a framework for a
world society in need of universal codes
based on Mutual consent in order to
function we must always remain Vigilant
to prevent these International standards
being contested by those who call into
question at the United Nations or
elsewhere the universality of these
human right principles this creeping
Demitri at the UN and elsewhere led by
the OIC and its agents and allies should
be denounced for what it is a return to
the
med to the medieval past in my
presentation at the European Parliament
conference in 2007 in 2010 I ended and I
would like to do with Sir Charles POA
you've used the part of the quote I
usually use the whole thing in his
analysis of Plato's criticism of
democracy so Carl
POA refers to a paradox of freedom and a
paradox of Tolerance here today once
again I would like to repeat the whole
words from his work unlimited tolerance
must lead to The Disappearance of
Tolerance if we extend unlimited
tolerance even to those who are
intolerant if we are not prepared to
defend a tolerant Society against the
onslaught of the intolerant then the
tolerant will be destroyed and tolerance
with them we should therefore claim in
the name of Tolerance the right not to
tolerate the intolerant we should claim
that any movement preaching intolerance
places itself outside the law and we
should consider incitement to
intolerance and persecution as criminal
in the same way as we should consider
incitement to murder or to kidnapping or
to the Revival of the slave trade as it
is in Sudan today thank
you wow
thank you very much I want to thank all
of our panelists uh we are over time